pis trois heures après le dénouement
donc chantre pasqua a tenu une
conférence de presse au ministère
l'occasion pour le ministre de
l'intérieur d' expliquer la stratégie
policière à savoir identifier le risque
privilégier le dialogue on l'a vu mais
aussi préparer une intervention en force
aussitôt l'alerté donnée j'ai défini le
cadre l'intervention de la police ne
rien faire qui puisse mettre en péril la
sécurité des enfants de l'institutrice
d'intervenir par la force que si cela
s'avérait compatibles avec la sécurité
des enfants
wang cas de menace immédiate de début de
violence à leur égard
n'acceptez and aucun cas que l'individu
et emmène avec lui des enfants dans sa
fuite
je voudrais naturellement signaler tout
particulièrement et adresser les
remerciements du gouvernement et aussi
les félicitations du gouvernement à
l'institutrice madame laurence dreyfuss
qui dans cette affaire a fait preuve à
la fois d'un courage exceptionnel et de
qualité professionnelle tout à fait
remarquable il convient également aussi
et je crois que le maire de neuilly et
qui est intervenue à de nombreuses
reprises en cette affaire n'a pas manqué
de le faire au peu de moyens de signaler
le calme et le courage des parents des
enfants notamment des six qui étaient
détenus à nouveau comme otages sans le
calme de ses parents et la confiance
qu'ils nous ont manifestée celle qu'ils
ont manifesté au maire de neuilly c'est
qu'ils ont manifesté aux responsables
efforts de sécurité
notre tâche aurait été rendue
extrêmement difficile pour ne pas dire
impossible
je voudrais également signaler le
comportement exceptionnel de madame
evelyne lambert médecin capitaine de la
brigade des sapeurs-pompiers de paris
ces deux femmes ont joué un rôle décisif
dans cette affaire elles nous ont permis
d'intervenir le moment venu dans de
bonnes conditions et aussi sans que les
enfants non seulement ne subissent pas
de violence mais je l'espère qu'il ne
reste dans leur esprit aucune trace de
cette affaire extrêmement délicate